let me ask you this what is your basic
definition of capitalism socialism
communism socialism is meaningless for
me I don't like the word because
everybody likes to be socialist today in
a vague sense yes society should take
care for everybody I mean by communism
no nothing totalitarian and so on
not central committee rules or whatever
simply such reorganization of economy
which consciously violate market
principles that the motive of production
is no longer profit we should for
example now when Trump is talking about
getting out of the lock down and start
moving to the economy but my idea is of
course we cannot hit all the time in
lockdown but here already I have a first
problem I've written about it for some
of us to be safely in lockdown quite
many things have to go on we discovered
it's health care food distribution and
so on and so on more important we should
violating market principles prioritize
things on which our survival as a normal
civilized society depends say health
care
forget about hospitals from a profitable
and so on and so on
we need an immensely strong health care
see we need to guarantee to distribution
and so on and just talking about this
I'm not saying states should own
everything and no cuz it feels to be
somehow coordinated socially coordinated
but you're not talking about the
communism that Marx and angles are
talking about in the communist very very
ambiguous Marx and Engels they were very
ambiguous Marx was fanatically insecure
and never provided definite if for
ballast you know his only moment of
enthusiasm was the Paris Commune
but the Paris Commune
was really more and Aniki sinks and
turning to women Chauhan nomadic by
irony when you asked me about communism
I will tell you what the states are
doing today
these are already elements of what they
call communism we don't have time for
respirator for masks to play all the
market game this simply has to be done
it's a matter of survival that's what
I'm talking that's different so let me
ask you this I want to be specific with
you here because please the premise the
foundation of communism in the book
Communist Manifesto the ten points you
know the ten points I'll go through I
just don't think you agree with all
these ten points no the one is abolished
of a property and land and application
of all rents and land to public purposes
a heavy progressive and graduated income
tax which I think you probably agree
with abolishing of all rights of
inheritance so inheritance you don't get
any of it
confiscation of the property of all
immigrants and rebels equal liability of
all to labor and establishment of
industrial armies especially for
agriculture the gradual abolition of
distinction between town and country
free education for all children in
public schools eliminating child labor
which you probably agree with
centralization of credit in the hands of
the state the state would control
communication and transportation the
state factories and instruments of
production would cultivate waste land
and improve the soil which of those ten
do you disagree with surprisingly we
tweaked a little bit agreed all good
ecologists need that one of the reasons
of our ecological predicament is this
imbalance between city and countryside
when societies were organized in a more
provincial way all the to eat waste and
so on all the minerals were basically
returned to land now products go from
lent agricultural products to the city
so we have to fertilize land and on the
other hand we have all the huge garbage
and so on so I don't think
even specifically communist demand is
last one about but again don't focus too
much on Communist Manifesto
it was never my favorite text I define
capitalism simply as system of
production where and it was after point
very successful where the idea is that
it will be most productive for society
most efficient who satisfied society's
needs if the motive is profit self
valuation circulation of capital
expansion and so on and so on I think we
are now in a situation where we cannot
rely on that and I think it's not just a
permanent sorry a short time crisis like
they say but it was similar in wealth
which wealth has to order production of
aircraft tanks whatever I think this
situation will last and I think that's
my secret hope this does not mean okay
we will all become China it can be done
in a more open flexible way than the
Chinese
you
[Music]